[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hello.
My name is Magnus
Hyttsten, and I
work on the Developers
Relation team here at Google.
I'm going to talk about
the new, exciting API
that we are launching called
the Google Drive Android API.
Here's where I plan
to cover today.
First of all, what is the
Google Drive Android API?
Then I'm going to talk
about the features it
has before I dig into two
very exciting ones, namely
the transparent offline
syncing and the user interface
component.
And finally, I will talk about
how the Google Drive Android
API relates to the
Storage Access Framework
API released with KitKat.
So first of all, what
is the Google Drive API?
It's a native Android
API written in Java
to access Google Drive content.
At this time, you might ask,
has this not been done before?
And the answer is yes, but
not as a native Android API.
And this is very
important, because we
have added a lot
of features that
enables you to create shiny,
first-class Google Drive
apps on Android even
without breaking a sweat.
One feature that makes
this API very useful
is that it incorporated
into Google Play services,
a core part of the
Android device, so to say.
And this has several
important benefits.
First of all, this greatly
reduces the app size,
which is perfect.
Since it enables the app
to be downloaded faster,
it does not need to
be updated as often.
And it makes the app have a
smaller execution footprint.
For example, it will not take up
as much memory, which is always
a great thing, of course.
But perhaps, an even
more exciting aspect
of the Google Play
Services integration
is that the API
will be compatible
running on all devices
starting with Gingerbread.
And this is no little
benefit as that
will include 98% of the
Android devices out there.
That means that you
can rest assured
that this API can be used
by everyone out there.
Just a tiny bit of devices
out there may not use it.
But most of them will.
And that brings us over to
the features of the API.
So pretty much
everything you need
to do to create a
great Google Drive app
is included in the API.
You can read, write,
update files and folders,
traverse folder trees,
view and update metadata.
There is a file
picker user interface.
And you have transparent
offline syncing.
So let's talk about that there's
a transparent offline syncing,
to begin with.
As you're aware, an Android
device is local storage,
but Google Drive storage
resides in the cloud.
Now, one little peculiar
thing about mobile devices
is that you can never
trust network connectivity.
It changes network
all the time, and it
is very often so that it has
no network access at all.
This makes storing things
in the cloud difficult.
But not with the
Google Drive API,
because the Google
Drive Android API,
we make sure that your app will
never fail when it writes data.
And should communication with
Google Drive not be possible,
the API will temporarily
store data locally
and later sync that
to Google Drive
once connectivity has
been reestablished.
For you as an Android developer,
this is, of course, great,
because it takes all
the error management
resulting from network
problems off your mind.
Another great feature of
the Google Drive Android API
is the user interface component.
And in the first
release of the API,
there is a folder and file
navigation and selector.
This makes it really easy to
write an application where
the user needs to
select folders or files.
The only thing you need to do
is display this file picker.
So how do you do that?
Well, first of all,
you create an intent,
which opens up the
file activity builder.
Then the actual magic happens
when the intent is fired.
The user will be able to select
the files or folders that they
want.
Once the user has
selected their files,
the result will be available
in the onActivityResult method,
as usual on Android.
And finally, you get the
Drive ID for the content
that you can work with.
Finally, I would like to
say some words on the KitKat
Storage API and how it relates
to the Google Drive Android
API.
Well, although both can
access and store information
on Google Drive, there are some
fundamental design differences.
The first one is that Google
Drive Android API only
works with Google Drive.
This allows Google to add
things to this API which
are specific to Google Drive.
On the other hand, the
Storage Access Framework
is a generic API.
And this enables it to work
with multiple different back-end
storage technologies,
not only Google Drive,
using a single interface.
And here is a big difference.
If you plan to do a very
tight and nice integration
to work Google
Drive for your app,
then Google Drive
Android API is perfect.
Another feature
of Google Drive is
that the developer
can safely assume
that the user has already
signed into Google Drive.
The Storage Access
Framework is excellent
if your app needs to
access multiple storage
technologies and not just Drive.
And of course, having
said all of this,
there is nothing
stopping you from using
both at the same time,
of course-- All Google
Drive-specific features as
well as a generic integration
with other storage technologies.
You should also be aware that
the Store Access Framework will
only work on devices that
are ground in KitKat.
And that's what I wanted
to present to you today.
We are very excited to launch
the Google Drive Android
API and the feature it contains.
Now go out there and
create great apps
using this Android
and Drive API.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.